[موسيقى]
تؤكد منظمه الصحه العالميه ان الحرق غير
المراقب للنفايات يؤدي الى انبعاث غاز
الديكسون وهو من المواد الشديده السميه
المسببه للسرطان
رافقنا داود عدنان عمر ابنه تجمع وادي ابو
هند البدوي الى بيته المتواضع لنطلع اكثر
على طبيعه الامراض التي يعاني منها كغيره
من سكان التجمع
والله انا عندي حساسيه على اعتذر عندي
ضيقه في التنفس بالليل برضو انا لما اجي
انام يعني بنام مرات على الكرسي لما نام
على الارض متضايق يصير عندي حساسيه باخذ
يعني دواء الحساسيه شايف والله انا اتوقع
انه من الجو ومن تربيه الجو المواطني احنا
اني بتوقع ان الحس لانه في كثير يعني
حالات زي هيك
[موسيقى]
طبعا احنا بنقدم خدماتنا لما يقارب
يعني كل زياره بيجينا ما يقارب الثمانين
مريض ما بين اطفال واصحاب امراض مزمنه وفي
عياده النسا
اطلع انا الدكتور جواد عن الدراسات التي
قام بها بالتعاون مع منظمه الصحه العالميه
التي تهتم بجوده المكان وجوده العيش
التقرير لخص بشكل اساسي ما قامت في سلطات
الاحتلال عبر السنين من تاثير على الواقع
العام للسكان وتغيير النمط السكاني
والتاثير على الصحه العامه لهذا النمط من
السكان وجد التقرير انه كثير من السكان
بيعانوا من الازمه بيعانوا من مرض اسمه سي
او بي دي سي او بي دي هو مرض الرئه بصير
تليف بالرئه غير قادرين على التنفس حساسيه
مفرطه عندهم طفح مفرط في النتيجه
الروائح المتكرره تركيز الروائح في
المناطق السكنيه المحيطه فيهم
وبالتالي كمان خلص التقرير لانه يجب عمل
مجموعه كبيره جدا من الدراسات الاضافيه
ومتابعتها من اصحاب
السلطات المعنيه في فلسطين من اجل متابعه
هذا الامر واثره على السكان في الحاضر
والمستقبل
حيثما تولي وجهك اثناء تنقلك في منطقتي
وادي ابو هندي ستلتقط عينك التلالا من
النفايات ولا يخطئ انفك الروائح الكريهه
التي تصادر حق هؤلاء في بيئه نظيفه
وهواء نقي
الضيوف اللي يجوا علينا اول مره احنا زي
كل الريحه علينا كل يوم موجوده
ضيوف اللي بيجوا علينا طوالي بس يوصلنا
يقول شو الريحه هاي شو وضعها يقول والله
احنا يا زلمه تعودنا على الوسخ اللي جنبنا
صحنا وقلنا يا عالم ايش هذا المجتمع هذا
المنطقه كيف هذول الناس راح يكون في عندهم
بالفعل مقدره على بناء شبكه
اللي حواليهم لما الناس بتمتنع عن زيارتهم
انا بقرا ناقوس الخطر لكل المسؤولين كل
المؤسسات كل الناس اصحاب الضمائر انهم
يوقفوا معنا
هذا الوضع اللي موجود
يعني لان الخطر وصل يعني انتهت الامور
نتمنى من المسؤولين اللي في البيئه الناس
اللي لهم مثلا
دور في المجتمع دور مع المؤسسات انه بنسلط
الضوء على هذا النقطه لانك صحيح في خطر في
المنطقه هذه منها احنا الحلال والاغنام
والاولاد والسكان والاطفال لصحيح جميعا
نحن في خطر منها
حسب الخبراء في مجال البيئه مئه عام هي
المده الزمنيه التي تحتاجها المنطقه
لتتعافى من اثر هذه الكارثه هذا اذا ما
بوشر العمل على معالجتها فورا هي اذا ارض
محروقه